- Okay, something I just
learned about you is
that you consider yourself an HSP.
What's an HSP?
- Oh, so I actually, this is a,
it stands for highly sensitive person.
I didn't know it was a thing.
I'm just like the way that I am.
Right, so apparently there's
a diagnosis they give you.
It's called a highly sensitive person.
And this actually came up.
So I'm starting a mental health podcast.
We're launching second week of January.
So right after "Call Me Kat",
I have a podcast called
"Mayim Bialik's Breakdown",
and we're, get it?
So I can say, "Welcome to my breakdown."
That's literally why we named it that.
But it's all about mental health.
It's all about all the things about us.
Not just what medication
you're supposed to take,
and what your life should look like,
it's real people talking
about their experience
with mental health.
I talk about my experiences.
So one of the things about
me is that I'm extremely,
I've always been called sensitive.
I've always been called hypersensitive.
And I was like, "You're just
trying to keep me down."
But it was someone we had
on my podcast who was like,
"Oh, it's called an HSP."
And I was like, "Now I have a diagnosis."
And it's a diagnosis for people
who feel things very, very deeply.
Sometimes they call us intuitives.
Sometimes they call
children Indigo children
if they're like this.
I'm like, I'm a hippie,
but that's too hippie.
Turns out it's not,
'cause I think it's true.
- I know, it sounds so
hippy-dippy but you're right.
- Science has caught up
with thousands of years
of Eastern medicine, of meditation.
Those things have science to them,
and that's what I'm trying
to break down for people.
This is where I wanna put
my time and my neuroscience.
- Well, I'm gonna tell you it's
crazy for me looking at you.
I feel like you have it all.
- No!
Oh my goodness!
- Beautiful, you're funny.
- Stop it.
- No, I'm just saying though.
It's important to point out
because we look at people
and we go, "Well, they probably,
they don't suffer as much
'cause they've got all
their cards together.
They got all their,"
I can't say that word.
I'm trying to think of another
word other than that (beep).
- No, but that's something
that I actually have sort of dived into,
especially with this podcast.
I have people on
who are far more outstanding,
attractive, successful.
And I'm like, "How do you do it?"
And you know what?
They're just like anyone
who wants to look deeply
at why their life isn't working
or why they don't feel good.
- But I think that makes
other people feel normal.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
'Cause we all-
- It sounds like my mother sent you a text
and was like, "Tell her she's beautiful
and she's got everything."
- I just love every time you're talking,
it comes in this voice.
- It's my favorite part.
- That's my mom's voice.
- Is it? I love that.
I love your mom already.